[Applaudissements]
parlons magie alors déjà pour parler de
la magie posons nous la question qu'est
ce que la magie
alors on a bien une définition qui nous
dit que la magie c'est l'art de produire
des effets merveilleux en invoquant des
puissances surnaturelles et bien voyons
ensemble qu'il n'y a rien de compliqué à
cela alors je m'appelle pablo cerveau je
suis étudiant de 22 ans en école
d'ingénieur ici et ça fait maintenant
sept ans que je travaille la magie au
travers d'une discipline bien
particulière le close-up la magie de
proximité qui se réalise directement au
contact du spectateur et moi c'est avec
des cartes que j'ai décidé de créer ma
nagy mais revenons à ce que je viens de
vous dire qu'il n'y avait rien de
compliqué à produire des effets
merveilleux en invoquant des puissances
surnaturelles
alors tout d'abord il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que je ne
suis le gourou d'une secte d'accord une
anse important je ne vais pas vous laver
le cerveau avec des théories fantastique
je reste un magicien
tout ce qu'il y a de plus rationnel
ensuite quand je voulais comme je vous
l'aï dit plus tôt
ça fait maintenant sept ans que j'évolue
dans le monde de la magie
j'ai passé des centaines d'heures à
travailler mes techniques de cartes et
pourquoi me direz-vous
et bien pour aujourd'hui être capable de
produire une magie qui me plaît et qui
plaît au public auprès duquel je la
réalise
et oui je suis d'accord là dedans rien à
l'air simple mais voilà
tout est dans la dernière phrase au
public auprès duquel je la réalise car
voyez-vous 80% du travail d'un magicien
consiste à s'occuper des autres et
surtout quand comme moi on fait du close
up à bâle à la magie ne se déroule pas
sur scène à une distance du public soit
lumière des projecteurs un peu quand je
me trouve devant vous maintenant non
quand on fait du close-up honte au front
au milieu des gens et vous imaginez bien
que ce public là va falloir apprendre à
le gérer à s'en occuper
à vrai dire c'est même pas un public que
vous trouvez au début d'un tour de magie
annonçait une somme d'individualités
tous ont leur personnalité leurs a
priori leurs attentes
et c'est de cette somme d'individualités
qu'on veut créer notre public et donc il
va falloir ramener les gens avec nous
pour les faire rêver éventuellement et
pour ça il ya quelques clés et vous
verrez que ses clés et peuvent s'étendre
bien au-delà du simple l'univers de la
magie et s'exploiter s'utiliser pour
n'importe quelle relation humaine
qu'elles soient amicales familiales
professionnelles amoureuse mais qu'en
est il de ces clés alors au travers de
mon expérience en magie j'ai pu
apprendre en construire quelques-unes
que je veux partager avec vous et libre
à vous d'ailleurs mais utiliser pour vos
prestations personnelles première chose
je ne démarre jamais par un tour de
magie
premier réflexe on sont la cible on
analyse notre groupe d'individualités
alors on se présente on rit on pose des
questions bref on s'installe si les gens
ne vous aiment pas ils n'aimeront pas
votre magie c'est ce qu'a dit art
illarine un magicien américain de 92 ans
peut lui faire confiance et c'est
d'autant plus vrai dans n'importe quelle
prestation au final si les gens ne vous
aiment pas ils n'aimeront pas ce que
vous allez dire donc on commence
par demander le prénom de nos
spectateurs alors pas tous évidemment ça
serait beaucoup trop long si on a une
grosse audience mais une ou deux
personnes pour démarrer faire un premier
tour une petite blague et ça va
permettre d'instaurer un climat de
confiance et de convivialité et surtout
de respect mutuel bonjour excuse moi de
te déranger comment t'appelles-tu oui
bonjour comment marc enchanté mac moi
c'est pablo marquez que je peux de
solliciter pour me dire stop quand tu
veux je te fais confiance marque soit
bon ici c'est la carte de marque on peut
applaudir marque
bravo marc bonjour comment vous
appelez-vous abidi alors je ne parle pas
exactement à la personne que je regarde
mais c'est pas grave
toi qui tu appelles abidji tu passes
après marc est ce que tu peux me dire
stop quand tu veux ici ça va et si je te
donne cette carte juste argentier de la
rendre à marc presque sans déconner
c'était à sienne mais ainsi deuxième clé
créer un lien avec nos spectateurs notre
interlocuteur alors pour ça on va
essayer de trouver des points communs
avec lui alors tous les indices sont
bons à prendre
ça peut être locaux d'une équipe de
sport sur un sac ou simplement un
t-shirt avec un groupe de musique qu'on
connaît l'importance est amené notre
interlocuteur a révélé un détail sur sa
personnalité qu'on s'empressera de
complémenter d'ailleurs ou pas parce que
voici l'ultime clé rester soi même
au final quand on fait une prestation on
ne veut surtout pas trop en faire au
risque de passer pour quelqu'un de vous
surtout en magie quand tout ce qu'on va
faire après va être totalement faux donc
autant être sérieux et verrait sur la
manière dont ce qu'on se présente c'est
important et donc rester vrai la
troisième clés pour appréhender notre
public
et bien voilà nous avons pris
connaissance de notre somme
d'individualités maintenant il faut
construire notre public on a pu déceler
des profils d'individualités et se
trouve que ces profils peuvent se
retrouver dans différents publics et les
méthodes pour les mettre à l'aise
peuvent donc ça prendre voici trois
profils le premier on adore tous
moi je l'appelle enthousiaste le premier
il adore la magie lui c'est un plaisir
de voir un magicien arrivé à sa table il
est ravi c'est votre meilleur allié
il rit à toutes vos blagues répond à
toutes vos questions on va l'utiliser
ah bah oui parce que l'enthousiaste le
mettre à l'aise pour quoi faire
il est super content nous on va s'en
servir pour nous mettre à l'aise on
traverse un moment difficile
quelque chose de sensible a annoncé
c'est vers l'enthousiaste qu'on se
tourne
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il nous
produira les réactions qui nous fera le
plus gagné en confiance et en énergie
indispensable pour la suite de notre
prestation
doc l'enthousiaste la clé avec lui c'est
de l'utiliser et de puiser son énergie
dans son regard dans son attitude
deuxième profil plus compliqué l'opposé
de l'enthousiaste moi je l'appelle le
réfractaire ah oui mesdames et messieurs
le réfractaire n'aime pas les tours de
passe passe
non le réfractaire n'est pas comme les
autres c'est un averti le réfractaire
compris quelque chose
il a percé un des mystères les plus
jalousement gardé par tous les magiciens
depuis la création de l'univers de la
magie le réfractaire a compris
que dans tous les tours il y a un truc
il est fort il est très fort et c'est à
partir de cette découverte traumatisante
sûrement arriver pendant son enfance
alors qu'il a découvert de manière un
peu trop brutale que la viscosité de
l'air ne permettait pas de fournir une
réaction support suffisante pour
supporter le poids par n est que de
toutes les manières ce dernier ne
voyageant pas la vitesse de la lumière
ne pouvait pas dilater le temps
suffisamment pour amener un ramoneur
vérifier le bon fonctionnement de toutes
les cheminées de la planète en mangeant
des cookies et buvant du lait en une
seule nuit
bref à partir de cette découverte le
réfractaire est obnubilé par une chose
voir le truc est bien montrons lui un
truc alors qu'on réalise un tour de
magie à l'enthousiaste on place le
réfractaire dans le bon angle pour
qu'ils voient la manipulation alors très
vite on lui fait un clin d'oeil il sait
qu on sait qu il sait le voilà complice
la clé avec le réfractaire le rendre
complice notre prestation pour qu'ils se
mettent à l'aise et soit avec nous
troisième profil plus spécial parce que
lui n'est ni contre vous ni avec vous ou
plutôt un peu c'est à dire que le
troisième profil je l'appelle le
pessimiste et le pessimiste bon point
pour lui tout va mal se passer
c'est un pessimiste mais surtout ils
n'arrivent pas à se concentrer sur la
prestation parce qu'ils ne pensent qu'à
une chose
et s'il se rate
s'il sera devant tout le monde ça va
être gênante j'ai pas envie de voir ça
donc ce pessimiste il va falloir le
détendre et le mettre à l'aise
alors on le regarde droit dans les yeux
et on lui fait un tour de magie qu'on
maîtrise parfaitement
on lui montre qu'on est légitime pour
notre prestation
une fois détendu il va pouvoir apprécier
le spectacle et le voilà rentré dans
notre public
alors des profils il y en a d'autres
il y en a plein d'autres on retrouve
plein de profil mais maintenant nous
avons un public
quand on a un public ébahi il faut créer
la magie c'est la prochaine étape créer
la magie
sauf que mesdames et messieurs nous
avons un problème de taille la magie ça
n'existe pas on est d'accord
1 la magie n'existe pas comme cette
lumière existent et marées dans les yeux
elle n'a rien d'aussi réel que ce
plancher n'en la magie n'existe pas en
tant que tel en revanche nous faisons
exister la magie à travers notre esprit
notre imagination et notre perception du
réel et au final le rôle d'un magicien
si de déclencher ce processus de
création de la magie dans la tête de ces
spectateurs par l'intermédiaire de
techniques et au final eh bien ce n'est
pas si compliqué en fait nous le faisons
tous tous les jours
en élevant un enfant lui permet de
devenir ce qu'il souhaite faire de ce
tout petit être humain un membre actif
de notre société faire apparaître des
cadeaux sous un sapin permettre à
quelqu'un de travailler pour nourrir sa
famille nourrir pour trame pour
travailler pour nourrir sa famille
redonner le sourire à quelqu'un qui
pensait que tout était perdu ou
permettre et une équipe de réaliser un
objectif qui semblait insurmontable
autrement dit amener les gens à se
réaliser car c'est ça la magie s'est
réalisée ou permettre aux autres de
réaliser des choses qui semblait
impossible souvent grâce à une vision
différente
une bonne manière de la présenter alors
en faisant de la magie j'ai choisi
d'aller à l'encontre de l'essence même
de ce qu'était la magie et voilà ce que
j'en pense aujourd'hui quand on fait un
tour de magie
quand on fait disparaître une cars quand
on change un billet la magie ne se
déroule pas au niveau de l'objet qui
disparaît car je vous le dis les cacher
quelque part non la magie se passe dans
nos têtes dans notre imagination qui va
percevoir le réel et créer la magie
intégré qu'il a disparu et c'est là que
la magie existe donc arrêtons de vouloir
croire en la magie ou bien d'attendre
qu'on me démontre qu'elle existe
c'est impossible plutôt apprenons à
lever les yeux et à observer devenons
créateur de magie
créons notre propre magie en levant les
yeux et en observant en observant pour
invoquer ces puissances surnaturelles et
produire des effets merveilleux car
c'est en observant que nous construirons
nos propres clés pour construire notre
propre public à savoir le reste du monde
et pour ça mesdames et messieurs pas
besoin de carte
[Applaudissements]